[Music]
my new book
head hand heart is essentially
about the struggle for status and
dignity in the 21st century
we have become too educationally
stratified in recent decades we've
allocated too much
prestige and reward to one of those
three
sets of aptitudes and that is
cognitive ability cognitive analytical
ability has become kind of the gold
standard of human esteem
in many rich western societies
and that is i think one of the factors
underlying
the mass political alienation we've seen
in recent decades
uh we also have and indeed the two
things overlap
big value divides that emerge have
emerged
partly along these lines of educational
stratification my last book wrote to
somewhere i talked about people see the
world from anywhere people who see the
world from somewhere
um this book sort of takes the argument
one step further on and
and tries to understand how it is that
so many of our fellow citizens feel
that society is not providing them
with the the status the prestige
the meaning um perhaps that they that
they seek
and um and i do think that this has a
great deal to do
with um not only the
uh the excessive focus
on just one form of human aptitude and
the way that
that has dominated our politics and our
economy and our culture
uh you see it absolutely everywhere and
so much so much contemporary
public policy the huge expansion i would
argue over expansion of higher education
the focus uh the overwhelming focus
uh in our in our lives on on the public
realm
and the kind of diminishment of the
private realm of
care and nurture uh the
um the disappearing status of you know
the
the value of of work
um as a sort of virtue in its own right
uh in in all sorts of different ways and
i think
one of the um one of the most important
things that's happened
as an expression of these
new relationships that many many people
feel are not really working for them one
of the most important things that has
happened
is we've even narrowed the definition of
what it is to lead a successful life
to lead a successful life now you have
to pass exams when you're young you have
to go to a more or less good university
and you have to have a more or less
successful
usually cognitive biased professional
career
um and
not everybody can or wants to do that
by definition and it will be a disaster
for our economies and societies
everybody did do that
there are vast numbers of things that uh
that
need to be done that don't fall into
that category um
moreover we have in recent decades
created a kind of single funnel
into that zone of
sort of safety and success we've created
a single funnel and that single funnel
is the modern university
uh if you go back 30 40 years there used
to be many more so little that there's
one big ladder up there there used to be
lots of little ladders up
it was possible to get if you hadn't
very well to school but we're pretty
able
uh you could there was promotion from
below is still possible in
in large organizations that has largely
disappeared if you don't have a degree
or even a postgraduate degree you can't
get into those organizations at least
into the into the top ranks of them uh
any longer um and
the system has become self-perpetuating
in a way about 40 percent
of jobs in our society are now graduate
only and the number of them
are growing the proportion of them are
growing um
so you know you know if you are an
anxious parent or a
or a kid 16 17 18
you know of course you're going to see
the path to university as the
as the only one um as the only show in
town really
um you know if you want a decent job
that is now what you have to do
um and um
meanwhile of course um well i mean i i
think we are
we are over producing obviously
we need we need high intelligence um uh
you know it goes without saying and this
is not a book
that is attacking intelligence at all we
need
we need high intelligence we need teams
of highly intelligent people
um you know cooperating across national
boundaries through the internet and so
on to
come up with a vaccine for kobe 19
most immediately but also to to solve
many of our
um technical and environmental problems
you know to find some way of sucking
the atmosphere so um it's not an
argument about that at all but it is an
argument about how we've
we've created um you know outside of the
the sort of
you know the elite band of highly abled
people
across lots of different professions
there is a huge great
sort of um bloated um
cognitive bureaucracy from people of
you know perfectly able people but
people mainly have kind of sort of you
know middling ability or
probably no more bright than most of
their non-graduate peers
and yet it's society is increasingly
designed um for them um
and as i say that this single path
into into higher education is the one
that is most clearly
signposted it's it's simple to
understand it's still
easily the most highly subsidized form
of post-school education
even despite high tuition fees
and meanwhile we have um enormous
skill shortages among skilled trades uh
amongst the
the middling technical functions that
are required to to make the whole system
work you know to make the
boiler in your house work to make
nuclear power stations work to you know
lots of those
middling technician type jobs that don't
necessarily require
a degree but require those sorts of in
the jargon of international education
those are level four level five
technical qualifications um and we're
producing
fewer and fewer people doing those kinds
of qualifications hundreds of thousands
of people used to do hmds and hnc's
every year now it's down to a few tens
of thousands if that
and we also of course have huge um
huge recruitment crisis in in
in care um in care jobs in nursing and
care
um i think 30 40 000
nurse shortages in the nhs uh pride that
was prior to the pandemic and the
pattern when i come onto this later i
think the pandemic
is is nudging us in some of the
directions that i want to see in terms
of
the redistribution of status across
across head hand and heart um so we have
recruitment crisis in nursing even
bigger recruitment crisis in social care
we're going to have to we have a huge
future demand for
specialist dementia nurses and
and currently we're not we're not
meeting those
those needs so we've um we've got out of
kilter
um we've got things that we've we've got
we've got the rewards
to to those clusters of different human
aptitudes out of kilter
now of course like i should also
emphasize
um to talk about head hand and heart
it's of course an abstraction i mean
i mean everything we do is a combination
of of kind of brain and emotion and body
obviously um but i still think it's
quite useful to sort of
as a sort of heuristic device to uh to
abstract and
and and certainly there are jobs that
that draw on
some of those some of those aptitudes
more than others
um so we've got out of kilter
um and it's going to become even worse
in the sense that it turns out that the
knowledge economy doesn't actually
need very many knowledge workers we're
seeing that
even before the real surge
of artificial intelligence artificial
intelligence is
has already arrived around the edges and
lots of different cognitive functions
are now being replaced by you know
automate automation did for blue collar
jobs ai
is increasingly going to do for uh for
at least the kind of middling and lower
level brain
jobs um so so few there will be fewer
jobs there will be fewer head jobs with
real
cognitive content as it were because as
i say the knowledge economy
doesn't actually need that many
knowledge workers and we're seeing that
already
even prior even prior to the
um the arrival of ai on a large scale
we're seeing it in things like the
decline in the
graduate income premium it's down in the
uk it's down to
um if you take into account pre-graduate
qualification so you compare someone
with the same a levels
one goes to university the other doesn't
the premium for the person that goes
to university particularly for males is
now below ten percent
uh we're also seeing um a
um a huge proportion of graduates
who are not in graduate employment even
ten years after graduating
and that's given a pretty elastic
definition of what a graduate job is
so um so we've got things out of
alignment
we're producing lots of people we
expanded higher education to produce the
kind of middle and lower
ends of the cognitive class many of
these jobs are not
actually going to exist in the future um
so we've got a we've got a skill
misalignment we've also i think in a way
got a political misalignment because
we're creating a huge crisis of
disappointed expectations
amongst um the people who you know young
people who feel that they have
done what was asked of them they've
worked hard they passed their exams
they've gone to university
and they have expected expected
to move smoothly into high status and
relatively high paid professional
employment
um but the proportion of that employment
in the total labor force has been pretty
static
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas